Ці поля - зовсім недалеко від гарячих точок,
до яких прикута увага всього світу.
Якщо піднятися на гору, то буде видно Вугледар,
Мар'їнку не буде видно, а Вугледар буде видно.
По прямій відстань близько 10-15 кілометрів від цього поля.
І це вже фронт.
Однак тут, біля Курахового, поруч із "дорогою життя" на Мар'їнку,
готуються сіяти соняшник. Попри те, що до полів дістають
ворожі снаряди.
Погано, як прилітають. Треба їздити і постійно дивитися.
Бо подарунків дуже багато в полях.
Ось такий вигляд має саме господарство.
Воно займається зерновими й овочами.
Сховище для зберігання овочів з холодильним устаткуванням.
Ну, приблизно на півтори тисячі тонн.
Капусти можна сюди покласти, можна картоплю покласти,
можна моркву, буряк, все, що хочеш, можна покласти.
Ну, "було" ключове слово в цьому випадку сховища.
Тепер це руїни.
На території підприємства було шість прильотів,
скільки в полях - ніхто не рахує.
Раніше тут працювали понад шістсот людей.
Нині лишилося менше сотні.
І снаряди, і прильоти, і відсутність робітників,
і ціни на добрива, насіння, паливо.
Дніпропетровська область - бензин, солярка 40-50 грн,
у Курахове - 60 - найближче місце, де можна купувати.
Все це на собівартість дуже-дуже впливає.
На деокупованій Харківщині бої вже не точаться.
Фермер Олег Гірман мав би виходити в поле,
утім чоловіку немає з чим працювати.
На його господарстві ще торік побували російські військові,
які вивезли все майно. Олег бачив це на записі
з камери спостереження.
Було дуже боляче.
І потім, коли спілкувався зі своїми колегами… Боляче…
У деяких розбили ферми повністю.
Хлопці розповідали, що ось так от заходили - корова стоїть.
Вистрелили, вбили корову, відрізали ногу на шашлик.
До повномасштабної війни на господарстві Олега
працювали 30 людей. За рік підприємство зазнало збитків
на майже 20 мільйонів гривень. Для малої ферми це - катастрофа.
До того ж росіяни залишили після себе приховану загрозу,
яка даватиметься взнаки десятиліттями.
Ось це їхні позиції були. Тому перед собою вони все мінували.
І ось це якраз мої всі поля. Що на ось цих крайніх полях -
можна лише здогадуватися.
Земля, яку Олег раніше обробляв, нині надто небезпечна -
на неї не можна заїжджати важкою технікою.
На мій погляд, це протитанкова міна.
Лежала вона ось тут поруч. А та, мабуть, була з якимось сюрпризом.
Харківщина - один з найбільш замінованих регіонів України.
Працювати в полі тут - небезпечно для життя.
Утім дехто готовий ризикувати.
Юрій наїхав на міну, коли був за кермом трактора.
Йому пощастило вижити.
Сюди, сюди… Тут більше, але так, нормально.
Буде ще довго заживати.
Отака рвана рана.
Залізних мало осколків, в основному пластик, гума.
Зараз нормально. У перший день було невесело дуже.
Попри небезпеку Юрій має намір і надалі працювати
й розміновувати поля власноруч.
Ось такі скарби він уже знаходив у землі.
Не я ж один. Не я перший.
Наскільки я знаю, в Україні не я перший і не останній,
це сто відсотків, підірвався.
Тим часом забруднені поля метр за метром перевіряють демінери.
Команда Halo Trust - одні з них. За словами фахівців,
від 30 до 40 відсотків території України треба ось так
прискіпливо оглянути, перш ніж їх можна буде
вважати безпечними.
Багато людей через замінування не можуть вільно
пересуватися по своїй землі, на своїх городах, виходити на пікнік.
З іншого боку, вони не можуть обробляти землю,
яка в більшості випадків є першим джерелом доходу для родини.
В Україні ми спостерігаємо, що кількість інцидентів
з мінами зростає.
На Донеччині замінування - не єдина проблема.
Ніхто не знає, де незабаром пролягатиме лінія фронту.
До того ж снаряди від "Смерчів" і "Ураганів" теж
залишають по собі тривалий слід.
Навіть якщо зібрати всі уламки, це засмічення,
все одно, якщо розірвався снаряд, є хімічне забруднення,
і якщо вирощувати на такому полі сільськогосподарську продукцію,
вона буде також за своїми показниками
непридатною для споживання у їжу.
Треба буде робити не просто механічну рекультивацію,
тобто загортати воронки, розрівнювати,
а ще й консервувати землю, щоб вивести ділянки
з сільськогосподарського обігу, щоб вони очистились
і засівати їх багаторічними травами, щоб минуло 5-10 років,
щоб земля очистилась і можна було вирощувати
на ній сільськогосподарську продукцію.
Господарство біля Курахового на Донеччині,
де працює Сергій, поки не планує відбудову.
Кажуть: після перемоги. Усе, що виростять, одразу продаватимуть,
бо зберігати ніде. Про те, аби полишити землю, мова не йде.
Тому що треба працювати. Куди його виїжджати?
Тут, і батьки мої тут, і я тут.
І будемо тут працювати.
Олег з Харківщини теж прагне повернутися до роботи.
Чоловік замислюється над тим, аби розміновувати
свої поля самотужки.
Якщо земля пустуватиме, каже фермер,
люди звідси поїдуть і більше не повернуться.